G
THE LAOP SRY AER URGING
EMPLOYEES TO TAKE UTION IT
GHT BE HACD.JOING USOW WITH RET,
E GRT ONE MARK LEV.MARK, ONE QU.
I WA TO Y OUT ONFACT.
BESIS ELON MUSK SANG
SHUTTI DOWDISSENTING VOIS,
WHICH THEY DID, IS BITS VERY
DEFINITION ELEION
INTEEREN.
THE FACT THATHFBI S INWEEKLY CTE
BIG CH COMPANIES, WAING THEM
OF AOSSIBLE HACK A LEAK
OPERION D EN ONEHAT
MIT DEAL WITH HUER BEN,
WH THEY HAD THE LAPTOP, MARKFOR.
THEYOULD'VE EASILYERIFD
THATT WAA REAL LAPTOP.
IT TELLS ME THEY WERPUTTING
THR FILMS ON THECALE AGA,
KE THEY DID IN 201AND THE
2020 PSIDEIAL ELECTION.
TELL ME YOUR THOUGHT>> WL, T FB.
'S NOTUST FROM THEOP DOW
AS JOEIDENIKES TO Y FROMTHE BOT,
ATEV THAT MEANS TH THERE'S
SOMEING QUESTION ABOUTHAT
WHICIS WHY WE ED TGET TH
SPEAKER OVER THEREN TH
REPUICANIDE ANGET  THE
BOTTOM OF THIS.
I WA TO TALK AUT AOUPLOF
E THGS RELATED TO IS.
THAT'S THI
IT'S VERCONVENIENT FOIFOR
THE PUBLICAN EABLIMENT IN
MEDIA TOEEP PLANING MAGAND
DONA TRUMP FORHEIROSSES.
DONA TRUMP HASN'T EN AROUND
FOREVER.
E REPUBLICAN EABLIMENT
HAS.
McCOELL I THINK HABEENN
THE SETE 36 OR 3YEAR
PULL T SAME STT IN 2010
WHENE WON 63OUSEEATS BUT
TH DIDN'T GET ENGH SEATS IN
THSENA.
YOU KNOW WHO HBLAM QUESTIOWHAT M
IN 200WHENEORGBUSH A OUR
FRIEND KARL RO LOSTHE
CORESS WOULD HAVE VEN TO
TH WHI THEY INHERITE THE
REPUBLICAN CGRESTHEY DIDT BLAMES
AND KARL ROV
NO, NO, NO, NO FURTHER PROBLEM
WI THE REPUBLICAN PAY IS
IT NOT A CONSERVATIVE RTY.
NOT A REAGAN PAR.
NOT TRUMPARTY.
IT A WASHINGTON CENTPART
WE'LL HAVE T REPLICANS DONE?
E
THE WORKS.WHAT IS IT TT McNNELL
WANTS TO DO?
HE WANTS TMEETHEM AT THE
40-YARD LI?
AT DO YOU MEAN.
WANT TO MEETHEM  THE
HOTD STA ANDAVE TH BUY
ME A HOTOG.ONE OF THE REPUBCANSN
McCOELL KEEPS GOINTO THE
MICROPNE A TALKING AUT,
ANYBODY TALKS ABT SUENDING
THE CONSTITUON C'T RUN F
PRESENT.
OBVISLY TALKING ABTRUMP.
E DECRATS ARE COTANT
SUSPDING THE CONSTUTION ANDRIPPA
McCONNELL,HEN'S THE LAST
TIME YOU TK ABT SEPARATION
OF PERS,IMITED GOVNMENT.EQUAL P.
DUE PRESS, PROBABLCAUSE FORRRAN.
OUR CONSTUTI IS ALREADY
BEINSUSPENDED.E FIREWALLS ANTHE
CONSTITUTI ARELREADY BEING
EACH.
BY THE DEMRATS
WHDO YOU WT TO MEETHEM ON
THE -YARD LINE?
WHAT ARE YOU GOI TO DOO GIVE
US OUR CONSTUTION BACK?
WHAT ARE Y GOING TDO T
PROTECT SEPARAON OPOWERS?
AT ARE YOUOING TO DO TO STOP
BIDES EXUTIVE ORDERS?
WHAT ARE YOU GOI TO DOO
RCE BIDEN TO ECUTE OUR LAWS
LIKE OUR IMMIGTION LAWS.
YOU CO TO THE MICROPNE AND
YOU BURP OUT WORDSITH THOSE
GUYS STANDG BEHIND YOU LE
YOU'RE IN A FUNEL PRESSION.
THATOESN FIX AAMN ING.
YORE AAYS LOOKING FOR FOS.HE RE.
INFLATN IS U
GASONE PCES ARUP.
PRODUCTI IS DOWN
'S SOMEBODELSE FAULT.
WHEN THEY LOSE THEIRLECTNS,
WHICH THEYONTROL FOR THEOST
PART, THEY ALWAYS BLE THE BASE
WHE TH ALWAYS BLAMSOMEBODY
ELSE.IT'S REALLY QUE DICULOUS BT
WHATAPPED TO McCN?
HE LOST WHAT HAPNED  ROMNEY?
LOS
TOOK SOMEBODY LIKE A TRUMP TO
N THE ESIDENCY BK AND IT
TOOK REAN TO END TWO MASSIVE
LANDSLIDESO WH'S THE
POSITION OF THSENATE
REBLICANS WHEN IT COMES  ALL
ESE ISSUES?
D KNS THERE'S A ZIION OF
THEM.
FROM THE BORDETONFLATIONOCELINE.
WHY DOT TH HE A COHERENT,
CONSISNT LISLATIVEGENDVERY BRIGS
ELTION
LET ME TELYOU Y  LOS
THESELECTIONS.
THERS NOING TO DO WITH
TRUM
IT HASOTHI TO DO WITH MA
COME ALL THE REST.
E GRTEST CANDIDATES,
FETTERN ISUMPING INTO WAS
I SAK.
HE'S NOTXACT A GREAT
NDIDATE.
BIDEN, ARE YOU KIDDING ME, TSE
AREN'TREAT CANDIDATETHEY HAVDES.
THE GORNORS IN THE STELEINVOLVE.
THAT'SHAT EY DID IFLORIDA.
IT'SIMPLE.
FIIT.
U'RE NOT GOI TO FIX , TH
STL THEIR SYSTEMROM THEM.VOTE EL
THE REST.
AT'S FINE.AND WHATLSE E NEED TO
INHIS COUNY?
THE ASONEOPLE DON'T VOTES
THEY DON HAVE REASON TO
TE.
WHAT WAS THE RUBLIPOSION
INFLAON, AT WE THEYGOING TOO?IO
CURE THE BORDE
WELLTHEY ARE ITHE NATE
NOW.
WHAT E THEY PROPOSIQUESTIONIKEG
ILLEIMMIATION, AMNESTYND
TIZEHIP EARLY WINT EVES.
THE BORDER IS DE ON.
LEGAIMMIGRANTS AREOMIN
INTHE PUBLICAN SOLION IS
CIZENSHIP.
TH ARE NOT GOINGSTOP WIT
CA
EY VE AGNST RELIGIOUS
FREEDOM.
WASN'T ABOUT RRIA.
THEY VOTED AGAST RIGIOUS
EEDOM.
WHARE EY WORKING WITH E
DEMOCRATS  THE MOST MAIVE
SPENNG BILL IN MODERAMERICAN
HISTORY?IT M NOT HPEN.
WHAT IS EIR AGENDA?
Y DOHEY NTEOPLE TO VOTE
FOR THEM.
WHY N'T EY EMBRACE CONCERN
AND PRINPLES PROVIDE OUT THETHIE
CCESSES OF TMP.
WH
CAUSE THEYE NOCONSERVATIVE
AND TH DON BELIEVE IN  AND
ASONG AS THIS GO O WE AREGOING D
FINALLY, H DIDHE DOCRATS
BEATS INEDISTRICTINGOST OF
THCOUNTRY?ERIC HOLDER  RUNNG AR.
YOU OW WHY?
THE FAILUROF THENC, THE
FAILURE OF T LITE COITTE
TH PUT TOGETHER TH O
FRIEND KARROVE.
WE ARE BEING OUTNNED BY THR
LAWYS.
GOING TOHE STES AND DOING
THESE VARIS THIN.
THE PUBLICAN ESTABSHME,
PUBLICAN RULINCLASHAS
FAIL U
THEY CTROLLED THE CONGRESS FOR
AND 40 YEARS.
WE BETTER OFAS A RESULT  IT?
NO.
WE AREOT.
THAT'S IT.>> Sean:HAT'WHY WE CAL
HIM E GRT ONE, MARLEVIN.